The Walking Dead Season 2 has now
finished and as promised I will review
the whole thing right here Telltale
Games The Walking Dead Season 2 so the
Walking Dead Season 2 was brought to us
by the Masters of pointing and clicking
and talking to people
Estelle's el games it's the story of
Clementine the first one she was a
little girl Lee had to protect and this
one this is all about Clementine coming
into her own becoming matured ultimately
relishing in it at least you relishing
in the fact that she has to do that
because there are a couple of calls you
have to make you're like you know what I
don't care I'm doing that Clementine
doesn't need to be protected by someone
who's trying to shelter her Clementine
needs to survive that's actually really
cool I like that dynamic in this series
this one took a couple of episodes to
get going I enjoyed the first couple of
episodes but ultimately its episode
three and four that are the peak of
everything five out and a couple of
moments in it I really liked it a couple
of heartbreaking moments depending on
how you play it but for me it was three
and four that was the [ __ ] and spoiler
alert I'm gonna spoil a few things for
you in this one I'll tell you when the
spoilers happens if it's a three there's
this dude this is spoiler alert for
episode three this guy runs his camp
he's a complete dick he treats it like a
prison and you guys are all themselves
and you're like we don't like it here
this guy's an [ __ ]
makes just one guy slap his daughter
he's like do it slap her hard
we'll wait I'm like oh so when the time
comes Kenny's gonna beat his ass to
death with a crowbar and Clementine can
go worst and I was like you know what
Lee wouldn't want her to watch this but
Lee ain't here and I watched it and it
was great because he was a dick I'm glad
he's dead yeah Kenny Kenny comes into it
Kenny comes into it in Episode two and
it was so awesome you see Kenny Kenny
was ultimately the one in season one
where you're like well you're a little
unstable but you know we like you until
we don't like you because you have
problems but we still love you until the
end he thought he died no he's in it
when you see him I'll never forget this
feeling it's like you see him and it's
like holy [ __ ] familiarity family hug me
until Kenny starts having problems again
and you're like I think Kenny's unstable
people are like Kenny's changed like he
has changed well really he hasn't
changed it all he's always kind of been
like that but you know same old same old
that old Kenny I'll tell you what
happened in the Walking Dead Season 2
for me I started to become wise to the
act and I didn't like that one of my
friends was watching me playing he chose
different paths from me spoiler alert
for episode 4 and 5 this lady gives
birth to a kid she's really weak do you
leave now Rudy you leave in five days
doesn't matter either way she dies and
when she dies everyone's like this
Mexican standoff like Reservoir Dogs and
[ __ ] happening when she dies you notice
that she's coming back to life as well
not like she's coming back as a zombie
and the babies in her hands I just rate
up shot her in the head and everyone
started shooting everyone that's when
the episode ended it was a firefight it
was a massacre and my friend told me he
called for help in which someone else
shoots her in the head and then it's a
firefight and it's a massacre
same outcome although you pick something
that you know you see what I mean I
didn't like the fact that I started
getting wise to that act after playing
three of these telltale games you start
going winner and it all just kind of
leads to the same thing like that
Russian kid I run into I didn't rob him
I was like no we're not gonna rob him
today here are your supplies I said oh
he'll remember that that's great but he
didn't ever remember that he was like oh
that's the girl that robbed me I looked
I didn't rob you someone else did by the
end of the game hands I'm shooting
Clementine in the shoulder anyway so I
was like I might as well have robbed him
didn't feel like it mattered that really
hit me in the face when Kenny came back
I loved the fact that he was back then I
was like wait a minute is that mean you
live in everyone's renditions of The
Walking Dead same outcome he drops into
the alley at the holy [ __ ] wait and it
kind of ruined the magic for me it's
like seeing behind the curtain of an
illusion you're like oh it's not as
special as I remember being doesn't
change the fact that you're left with a
story that is really engaging and by the
end you cry because that's just how
these Walking Dead games are they're
really emotional you get attached to the
characters I ultimately the first ending
I I got a [ __ ] ending I was like well I
was kind of anticlimactic and then I
heard the better ending is an ended
spoiler alert for episode 5 I'm spoiling
the whole thing at this point there's
one chicks like oh the baby's dead but
she just hid the baby from Clementine so
Clementine could seek any rage out
ultimately have Kenny murder this lady
then you find out the baby's alive and
she was kind of out of her mind like
okay and then Kenny and her go to this
place and they're like we can't take you
all in Kenny's like we just take the
kids take the little baby and take
Clementine I'll stay behind and that
goodbye drove me to man tears it was
really good because although Kenny was
losing his mind throughout the game it
was just it was great to see him
actually be the man you know he is deep
down it's like Boromir it's like yeah
Boromir dict out for a second but that's
not what Boromir is boromir's the man
who gave his life for merry and pippin
took arrows like Mike Ehrmantraut lawyer
took SHIVs yeah you know what I'm
talking about it made me forget the fact
that the illusion of these telltale
games are the fact all of these
they're ultimately herded to reach the
same outcome except for the very end of
this game which is clearly different
they can have like four or five
different endings which makes me think
in season three they're going to have
something that negates everything or
they're going to have a different
character entirely in the end The
Walking Dead Season two started out a
little slow in the first two episodes
although the first two episodes were
very enjoyable you need to start
noticing the pattern that wait a minute
how I play really doesn't matter it's
just all about will it shows you how you
would do it I guess it's very nice in
that reflective kind of way I just wish
that the choices would lead to a
drastically different outcome that would
stick like The Walking Dead
500 days of summer but like what how
does that feed into this really it
didn't do anything for the story that I
noticed I just feel like telltale
Games's like it's gonna be relevant and
[ __ ] and thank you for five bucks it
kind of irritated me that the difference
wasn't so there that it's like that's
why it's different that's why you had to
play G I don't feel you did however The
Walking Dead Season 2 episodes 3 4 & 5
were badass a lot of tension to slow
down near the end but that's where all
the really tense [ __ ] within the group
that I was in was happening got a lot of
walkers but a lot of conflict I will say
The Walking Dead Season 2 is worth
buying at full price I love the growth
that Clementine goes to and this goes
perfectly with season 1 1 & 2 or just a
great solid game right there buy the
season pass for like 20 bucks you'll
have a blast so if I could give a
message to telltale games it's that for
the next one have the actions and
consequences be vastly different have it
a different gaming experience entirely
even if that means Episode four is not
going to tie in with Episode three I
would like to see that happen a
self-contained game where by the end
that's a completely different game of
different people are alive different
people are dead my friend and I don't
have the same game by the end I'd love
to see that [ __ ] so the Walking Dead
Season 2 you have you played it what did
you think about it do you agree with me
on the choices and actions and
consequences ultimately leading to the
same thing whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you